chillin downstairs right and like just
out of nowhere I hear a big bang boom
upstairs right I don't know what it is
cuz I'm home alone so if there's
actually something here then I'm scared
here hold on I see if you came here to
kill me clap your hands me review
everybody YouTube's favorite show
special news announcement good evening
my name is Gloria Borger I work for me
in review now doing the special new
coverage of memes and your whatever you
need to know about memes this just in
last week
neck man very large neck look at that
neck I'm sorry but do you see that neck
very big neck man was arrested but it
turns out he made a friend I love when
use our wholesome I know I'm not
supposed to give my own opinion but this
is a beautiful thing
wide neck meets up with long neck it's
the yin and the yang wide neck and long
neck perfectly balanced as all things
should be I don't wanna care about to
beat his ass way everybody there
on this matter
[Music]
[Applause]
all necks matter I'm not supposed to add
my own opinion on meme review but smash
like if you agree with this message I
mean I I'm not supposed to add my own
opinion but this seems like the most
ambitious anime crossover since the Lion
King I mean just look at these two how
can you not love them all I mean next
news comes from stairs that's right
everybody last week we covered staffs
scientists have debated for so long for
centuries for eons what is the most
effective way to go upstairs do you want
one step at a time or do you walk two
steps at a time let's look at the
climbing stairs and how much pop lab lab
lab pseudoscience don't waste my time
everyone knows it goes like this one
step at a time
bunch of virgin losers two steps at a
time you're slightly better three steps
at a time you're an absolute champ
sixteen steps at a time
you're practically God but what
scientists now from carefully studying
the data has now revealed that the
ultimate way to walk up the stairs
revealing first time live here a meme
review as Gloria Borger is to crawl up
the stairs
you're not output unless you crawl up
[Music]
next news next news comes from Florida
Florida which of course is the most
insane place in the world where you get
the best headlines Florida man accused
of attacking girlfriend with banana okay
as Florida man force to suck or does or
now incoming new Florida man Florida man
claims he only drank at stoplight and
normal driving the god bless see Freud
Lafleur god bless that was it for Gloria
Borger let's begin meme review they did
surgery on a great
[Music]
one ascribe Grand Prix apparently this
one's a meme decided to be the absolute
worst and very related coincidence I
don't think so
this is another corporate shill paying
their waves in two means and I'm not
buying it I'm not buying it sprite oh
they got me
this is multi-layered marketing you
understand that right
garner foot-high some mood swings sprite
for a Bri there's no emotions girlfriend
can't touch her without girlfriend
LeBron doesn't even know her sponsored
by ok but like what does it taste like
but like does it taste like cranberry
cuz like I kinda want to try it know if
you want to waste your money then buy
the PDP merch link in the description
none of this cranberry you've stranded
in the desert it's a hundred degrees you
have no water as you begin to fade away
he reaches out to you wanna sprite
cranberry I feel like I have not
explained this meme really stupid
commercial with LeBron James going you
want a sprite cambrie that's eight I
don't know if you expected anything no I
don't LeBron James no I freakin don't
stop asking me please
despite how absolute trash this me miss
that's right I call the trash there are
some good ones out of it like LeBron
James breaking into your house to offer
you sprite cranberry ASMR
now I don't just for the Brawn oh my god
Jesus Christ LeBron now I know what
you're all thinking
does it actually taste like cranberry
well I have not tried it but I have
Timothy Birmingham who was clearly
before his time three years drinking a
sprite cranberry let's see what he has
to say hey everyone how you doing my
name is Timothy hello and I will be
trying oh my god waste
thanks so much sprite cranberry that is
a lot of sprite Camry and you cannot
argue with that cranberry yes right
cranberry alright so what do you got for
us Timothy what does it taste like
Stella please you taste so I know that
what does it taste like Timothy
well I'll say I got a rate does yes
please rate it oh my god um I got a rate
in it what are you writing it Timothy I
got a raise please please Timothy oh my
god Timothy a three a three
this right Cranberry mean gets also a
free-thinking with a Birmingham Thank
You Matthew hey Barry
did you know that they did surgery on a
grape introducing new meme format we
announced new meme format cuando alguien
Esther destroy endo to Vidya eres tu
mismo what does this mean I don't know
what does this meme ha ha ha ha ha
global warming humanity migrates me ha
ha that's relatable when you finally
catch that mother that's been holding
you down introducing a new meaning
segment everybody this one is called not
quite ready to die that's right
two are a little kill them we have muy
that's right the Easter Island emoji can
I get an Easter Island movie emoji in
the chat thank you very much we I of
course is everywhere we've seen him
everywhere from from pop culture to
classic culture to whatever this is we I
it's just there I like that I like that
I like that a lot I like it I like it
so much like if you can hear this image
right now I'm gonna say the n-word bro
well freakin gosh darn it muy I'm gonna
have to kill you now it's image another
meme that kind of has been popping out a
bit more worried son it's kind of funny
you have these videos where pretending
to shower as the Black Parade plays out
of an iPod Touch while on vacation with
your parents ASMR or perhaps your
parents are arguing downstairs about
divorce while you're crying all while
mr. Brightside plays ASMR but my
personal favorite I know I'm not
supposed to give my opinion
it's the LeBron James of breaking into
your house to offer you
sprite cranberry ASMR no I don't want a
sprite cranberry leave me alone LeBron
James
another meme not quite ready to die is
the PETA tweet that came out yesterday
urging people to stop using anti animal
language such as don't say kill two
birds with one stone say Peter horse you
think anyone's gonna say hey you really
hey can you stop that you're really
feeding a horse huh you're really
feeding a horse with that one you're not
even making any goddamn sense PETA
you're saying that by this context you
will say stop feeding the horse this of
course gets parody jacksFilms posted
instead of saying happy holidays
s MH say may your Christmas be filled
with Christmas what day is it how many
days till Christmas or a grande who
posted kill two birds with a stone say
two games with one bundle oh this is the
gamer language version the very epic I
see potential what can I say maybe you
want to invest maybe you don't all right
make your own goddamn decision I'm not
here to tell you how to think or what to
do can we get an actual meme Felix okay
roses are red a bells - chime DVD
screensaver hits corner four freaking
times now I'm told that this has only
happened once where the corner hits four
times I have never witnessed it
I never seen this miracle with my own
eyes but I can only dream that one day I
will be blessed with this did that
really just happen did I really just
witness that oh yeah did I really just
miss that good oh you see when the DVD
bouncing thing logo hits the corner that
is too sweet euphoria that's how you
know you can die a happy man
it's the ultimate pleasure known to
mankind you kids have your call of duty
epic 360 montages but you will never
understand what it's really meant to
witness one of these sometimes it looks
like it's heading right into the corner
of the screen and then the last minute
hits a wall and bounces away and we are
all just dying to see it go right into
the corner
Pam claims that she saw it one day when
she was alone in the conference room
okay I believe she thinks she saw it I
saw it I saw it and it was amazing women
cannot see it don't make me laugh smh
okay then watching this oh that was a
bit anti-climatic it just hit out of
nowhere i I wasn't even ready for it wow
did you see that no reaction no reaction
no reaction this is what I'm talking
about women they cannot witness the DVD
screen I'm not being sexist this is not
sexism okay but women I'm women cannot
see in the corner and if you think that
is just lice made-up then I don't know
what to tell you you liar you like your
other liar here we go I'm not I'm gonna
watch the whole thing
here we go hit the corner come on come
on daddy needs daddy needs an epic
reaction come on is it oh yeah see
that's the thing it tricks you you think
it's gonna hit it and then it bounces
gosh damn it
- freakin tamid come on dvd-video come
on I'm not in this video until he hits
the goddamn thing in the corner come on
what if I change the size of this recess
goddamn it I can't even cheat it which I
would never do
come on dvd-video come on come on
dvd-video come on hit the corner hit the
corner hit the damn it that was close
come on do you is it gonna do it oh damn
that was really good is it gonna do it
ah damn that was really close
okay come on dvd-video corner come on
come on dvd-video corner oh is it gonna
do he's gonna do it's good it's good
it's good oh I thought it was gonna hit
it he's gonna do it oh I thought it was
gonna hit it it's gonna okay come on
dvd-video corner come on give it evideo
corner come on is it gonna do it oh come
on come on come on oh that was close oh
come on dude just once I just need it
once I just need it once
come on today's gonna do it's gonna do
it Oh
[Music]
that was mean with you hope you guys
enjoyed and as always remember like four
summers ignore four James Charles
[Music]
[Applause]